oh wow it's like five-second delay maybe
be a drug delay oh no all right so I got
a lot of custom stories to play for you
both tonight I'm excited I wish I could
see what you're writing the side won't
load for me I think we broke it
this is my gift there's like how many
people are in here oh my god it's over I
can't even see I sold 4,000 almost
before
that's crazy yeah crazy everyone is
crazy hey there's a shot hello everyone
all right holy [ __ ]
hey 4,000 it's over 4,000 what are you
doing before we start can I just like to
start some things to say that this
working can you hear me well according
to the game that me now would be a great
time all right
it's kind of [ __ ] out Wow all right
god I never seen I remember the last
time when I do the stream it was 600
people and I was like it was out of
control and I was four oh I don't even
know anymore
it will probably be 5,000 all right
let's start with
I don't know which one I'm gonna start
Wayne advised house or provide nightmare
all you played I think I think Utley
should I play through the White House I
know how I play that yeah much in some
didn't show me pretty house but then
when I entered this house doors close
behind me
I was jailed most is at home in this
house I have to escape and fast all
right I mean it seven we might have so
started hey you can actually sit alone
if you know yeah I'm acting your dream
up team hey I should close brats right
laps down everyone is happy happy how
I'm sure so how you doing Ally Sinclair
I'm in the livestream
that's amazing like I'm so excited I'm
surprised I could place actually I'm
famous oh my god oh my god oh we got the
handle alright yes oh man I just laughs
right Wow
what are you doing in my house this is
my house no perros is allowed in my
house why do you why would you keep
barrels in a place like this is that
keeping barrels in holy [ __ ] or browsing
the closet yeah dammit I hate to put us
in the closet how does it bro always
come out of a closet make a love Lance I
love reading
I think the father is near just check
the other room
ah and there's a cigarette you just find
how to God
but have Meccan on sales hey close a
loafer and before I continue is it good
like the sound good
is it alright let's call it good is it
delay I'm a big advocate and fight on my
brow all right don't try it it's my
little brother all right
you have some problem knife right while
I wait for your answer
all right everyone says it's fine so
I'll just you're gonna go pal I bet the
bowels are responsible let's find
Stefano burrows
I bet he's here somewhere so mr. Bhalla
but father what hello sweetie
this is my father Bruce the IRA replicas
I am very uh Stefano however are you
sure about that yes of course
what about this one I like this one it
pretty - peace out this guy's I hit my
head is there anything in the act
why would I lose the quality all right
which one should I take me with me bros
the big one small one ah it's lagging
guys no it's not lagging big fella
I got the leg I don't even know let's
just go I'm sure it's fine Jesus Christ
your brother like aa sub Rose so how'd
you doing a nice name and get to a licen
with this eyebrows are you doing here
okay I don't last yeah Jesus Christ
sup with this place don't trust any of
these alright Stefano let's just put in
there down wrap you gotta be something
under the boxes I'm wasting my Latin I
like that no one is saying that fixing
well at it there we go it's more food
hey where's the pond ago shut up okay
all right don't almost stuff just let
the frigging status out of control
anyway I think we need to ah what why
would you do that it's impossible to
make a oh oh I need to climb up there
all right you go first Hanapepe nice all
right
oh I just go here and then see it
alright
Beryl get out of my way barrels Nicoli
shootable alright I mean it's not
YouTube quality but I don't know I don't
know it seems fine on my computer so I'm
gonna go like that I'm sorry I can't
please everyone thank you by the way for
everyone who's here even though it's
probably like 5 min the morning or
something like that I promise next
iostream I'll do it in a different time
but I really appreciate Parrish I lost
there all right let's go continue ok
nothing here oh that's great anyone
played it's not before usually I find
something oh it's a barrel key and don't
do it better
it's the tap like it you stuck no no
father penny I'm stuck you need to
continue without me
alright fine on this question so what
did I do
what did I do what what what why why am
I wasting my lantern it sounded like I
did something I don't know okay let's
stick over here by the sauna or maybe
here lies the class is closed
who closed the closet oh damn it so many
second it's so crude to this room
hey what happened here remove the closet
hey secret rooms
alright I'll take this one with me hi
here's the guy found the biggest asana
today a tomato we didn't expect I had
okay fine I'll take the middle Stefano
alright let's continue
it's so good yeah it's loading I'm sorry
Jesus Christ
hey pause thousand people holy [ __ ]
five thousand Raghava I uh I don't even
know anymore
a lot of people are saying is lagging I
don't know it was finding me I'm fine
sorry I am blue-on-blue MIT I'm a Diane
I'm og I'm gonna die I'm green ah I love
death end of yeah get out of my get that
this is why you can't trust that use
they always entrust themselves they
don't appreciate when they address
themselves
I need a sandy poison no address that I
knew that that's that's my line describe
take the key in the chefs today and the
desk whatever I don't see a desk love
cut up any how do you care about it
oh let me just shake is it really
lagging okay I understand if it's like
delay and there's nothing I can do about
hey like them you think you're tough huh
you think you're tough well guess what
we're not just the bottom hey piggies
yeah a book I'm so bigoted but hey how
you doing hide my name hey my name is
piggy
I'm so pretty pump up it's pretty pile
ice cream so somebody broke oh my love
hey bro I just want to tell you I really
appreciate you know if anyone ever feels
alone and you know need someone to come
with here by the fire you know I know
there's a lot of you I know there's a
lot of lonely people who wants to cuddle
me by the fire you know I'll be
available you can call me just talk to
Pete vine who hooked me up all right
it's a cool bit about yeah sure oh I
guess I can hook you out you I
appreciate man I really appreciate I'm
real pumped you know all right
love cosmic piggy let's continue hey
look it's big yeah oh really oh really
I'm so do boom all right let's look for
a key I love this no chase I'm pumped
but I don't know what I'm sharp E I just
don't know I can't tell you with it all
right let's go
last girl in super slo-mo all right
did everyone get kicked or something how
loud no it's just 5,200 Wow get out of
my house this is my house I probably
wouldn't have decorated this PLA but
okay let it be barrels down there
[ __ ] book bow you scared me what are
you doing
it's all good what
holy [ __ ] I'm out of here how's the cell
don't look at me like that okay
ha pity Oh God Halla pity how you doing
pretty high Dimpy company a lot pity I
waited for you come here and hug me mmm
I just want to hug you so much I love
you Petey
I'm your buddy step on up he's not here
anymore you should trust me I'm a chef
okay care mode activated okay helping me
really way holy [ __ ] I told you pity I
told you a million times you never
listen you never listen
I can't damn it don't worry bro
the she'll help you down tonight so
everybody need a hammer all right why
howdy a many times you did you read in
ER all right why I'm up to that you
thought okay a million times just relax
and do share mo and you'll be fine you
should reason why I'm a share you know
when I grew up I want to become a share
and look at me look what I have I'm a
living truth that anything you want can
become true mmm
mmm-hmm I don't I don't know if I want
to ask what you were before mr. Sherr
back okay hey what is this address this
place but this is a shot I don't trust
any of it all right all right cogwheels
I definitely don't trust you clock yeah
clocks all right I guess what is this
some kind of dildo probably i can assume
just go like you should show this to
piggy I surely appreciate it I'll put it
here I remember okay what is this pretty
Mario
I don't listen sound delicious hey what
get out of my way potatoes i am i doing
analyzing i just want to be in life in
jesus christ all right all right all
right you will be my i don't know poor
bro some [ __ ] idiot puts him in the
put him in the closet and talk to him
they are gonna pay for this what huh
what what what no I waited for it eh
[Music]
all right let's go here always said
penis everywhere